[Music]
let's go to
tynan in kansas city kansas hey tynan
how are you
i'm doing well how about yourself we are
rocking and rolling so what in the
world's going on how can i help
yes
um so the reason i called is
um we lost our 14 month old daughter
earlier this month and a drowning
incident oh
godly yeah hardest days of our lives
absolutely you're still in the middle of
them
we are yeah we definitely are yeah oh my
goodness were you there
uh yes i was um my husband was not um he
had to travel a couple hours to get to
us oh man i'm so so sorry
oh thank you thank you
um
so we have two older kids a four and a
half year old and a three-year-old and
then we have a new baby due in six weeks
oh my gosh
yeah so my question for you you're super
super pregnant right now
yeah uh babies due at the end of october
it'll be here any time
that laugh that you just gave was
was not a funny laugh it was uh this is
happening left right
yeah this is life yeah
for sure it's the guy at the bar that
realizes oh we're getting a fistfight
and he smiles that's what you just did
so yeah
um so in six weeks you're having another
baby right in the baby wow okay can i
can i
ask you something um
real i mean we're in a personal
conversation here
yeah you sound incredibly detached
is that where you've had to park for the
last couple of weeks
um
yes
yes and no okay um you know
yeah after the incident um you know our
daughter fought really hard for a week
so we were in the picu for a week
and um
yeah i'm very frustrated
that i was pregnant because i wanted all
of my energy and stuff to be
you know for her um and it was hard to
take care of myself and this baby during
that and then um
yeah and then we we lost her and you
know and then the weeks have gone on and
yeah
yeah it's yeah so i guess my question
through that is how are we supposed to
navigate through the grief and the guilt
in a way that also allows us to fully
experience
the joy of bringing another new life
into this world
um from our previous kids we know it's
going to be amazing but at the same time
we just have this profound sadness that
makes it seem like this is going to be a
bittersweet miracle
yeah
it is
yeah
one of the things that you're
putting on yourself right now is a
right way to do this
and it you've got a picture of what your
other three births were that joy and the
in the chaos and the laughter and the
late nights and all that stuff
but there's that under
underneath that foundational sense of
joy and connection and this is our
family
and
you're imposing that on this situation
it's a totally different situation
yeah and
one of the cornerstones of of
grief that melts people is expectation
on how it's supposed to go
yeah that's the hardest thing it is it's
so hard
and so for you letting go
of this idea that you're gonna be
stealing from this new kid you're not
this baby's gonna be loved so
unimaginably deep
and this baby was born in the back end
of a pandemic just what just was right
this baby was born in the middle of the
darkest moments of
his or her parents entire life
and that's just a reality for this kid
does that mean your kid's gonna love be
loved less no does that mean mom and dad
are gonna sometimes have to hand the
baby off and go
weep on all fours in their in their room
alone yes it does
and so
what you and your husband have to do is
let go of the it should be like this
and experience the it is like this
and then you've got to be extra
intentional about having people around
you they're going to walk with you
through this season because it's going
to be different it's going to be hard
yeah and that's been the hardest thing
for us is being vulnerable to letting
other people help help us
um we have been blessed with amazing
family friends and a small community and
um that's that is definitely the hardest
part is being vulnerable
so my guess is
your ability to talk with me right now
and articulate things the way you are
lets me know that you are
you are still fully in
um
fight or flight you're still
you're still gunning does that make
sense
yeah and it could be because you're
pregnant it could be you have two little
ones and you don't have time because
they've got to eat and have their
diapers changed and they got to get to
where they got to get
and husbands still got to go earn a live
all those things right
um yeah
you must make space for this
because it'll come for you okay
yeah and that's not a bad thing that's a
good thing that's how we're designed but
you've yet that
so here's a couple things let me let me
back out a little bit um
you will at
over time be able to pull apart the
grief from the guilt okay
what i don't want you to do is to add
any more guilt
in the future than what you're already
carrying
does that make sense okay so you're
going to try your said than done of
course it is so here's what's really
important is making sure you've got a
daily journaling practice where you're
writing these things down and what that
does is it keeps them from settling in
for lack of better terms this analogy
it keeps them from settling in your
backpack and becoming part of you
okay okay and so having a steady flow if
you and your husband are able to do this
together it's really great is you read
these out loud
and
there's something profound
grief demands a witness
and so this often wrecks families and
here's why because there becomes this i
need you just to be done with this or
why are you still worried about this or
he grieves like this and you grieve like
that
and it's the expectation on how we
should be grieving and what we should be
doing by now and it's been four months
or it's been two years or it's been
whatever or we're taking the pictures
off the wall no we're not and there's
not space for people to grieve on their
own but you don't grieve alone you
grieve together you just do it
differently
and so the way you do that is checking
in with one another and just being
gracious with space because everybody
does it different does that make sense
okay
yep that makes sense and so it's less
about we need to do these things
and more about
30 minutes every day we're gonna check
in with one another all kids are out
we're not gonna be around their kids and
even if that means we're gonna have to
get a neighbor to come over for an hour
and evening
and just let us have some space and
we're gonna look at each other in the
eyes and say where are you
and they're gonna say i'm okay and then
there's gonna be seasons where you feel
guilty because you don't feel bad that
day right yeah or you're gonna have days
that you wake up and you're running
around with two kids and you go into
appointment and then you didn't think
about
your baby the past and then you're gonna
all of a sudden be overwhelmed with
guilt and what kind of mom am i and all
those are things you gotta write down
and process with somebody okay
okay okay and over time that grief and
guilt will pull apart so
i
knew this call was coming and i called a
close buddy of mine who's a licensed
therapist who also experienced something
similar
and um
he gave me some really great
um insight and happened to be pregnant
in the very very similar he wasn't
pregnant obviously his wife was but um
they were going through the same thing
yeah one of the things he strongly
recommended is to let you know
that this baby
will not be a replacement
this isn't gonna be an instead of and it
might feel like that way right now once
you hold this baby you'll know that
they're not
yeah and he strongly recommended keeping
pictures up i asked him i said you still
have pictures up and he actually took a
picture of the wall with all his kids
photos
and he's got the picture of his youngest
still there and they celebrate birthdays
so it just becomes the rhythm of your
family right good okay there's not a
right or way to do this that's the key
there
okay
being certain
whether you put up stockings at
christmas whether you said a place at
thanksgiving and everybody writes a
letter and puts it in her stocking or
puts it you know whatever those things
are will become a rhythm of your family
and it's the things that don't keep you
from not crying that's not the point the
point is that yeah in love right
yes how's husband doing
he's he's doing pretty good okay um yeah
we have my four and a half year old we
have happy sad days where parts of our
days are happy and parts of our days are
sad and that is just so true
so can i tell you the greatest greatest
greatest gift you can give your kids
yes please do is let them see you be sad
yes let them see you grieve
um if you all decide hey we're going to
draw a picture uh what was the baby
who's passed away what was what was her
name
her name was clara yeah
they draw a picture for clara
they write a note to clara even if you
write maybe a a elevated note to clara
and you read it to them and let them
know that you really miss clara
and it shows them that it's okay that
they miss clara
yeah you know what i mean
and when you next time the kids are
gonna go swimming and your heart rate
takes off
you can hold their hands and tell them
hey mommy's nervous
because i miss clara and they'll get
that and they won't feel crazy does that
make sense yeah
that makes total sense yeah the tendency
is to hide
our feelings because we want to scare
our little kids and what it does is it
makes them feel terrified of their own
feelings because they're scared too
yeah
yeah and if dad cries and he can hold
your two little ones and
the brand new baby all of it right
i'm heartbroken for you
thank you
thank you we yeah we we miss her
terribly but we also have 100 confidence
that she is healed and she's hold and
she is perfect in heaven and
we will see her again it doesn't take
away the pain of missing her down here
but
that's that's the the confidence we
could have right now
so one of the the great demons of these
kind of of these seasons that i've seen
over and over and over is a lot of
really
well-meaning people
say the worst things
and
you get flooded with dumb books and
internet links and blah blah blah okay
so i don't want to pile up on that
um i do want to recommend you and your
husband pick up a book called
finding meaning by david kessler
okay and he is the world's renowned
grief expert it's the single greatest
book my career has been in grief and
this is the greatest book i've ever read
and what makes it beautiful and unique
is he's the top scientist in the world
when it comes to grief
and then he lost his son
and
the the the narrative that weaves
through the book is i wanted to go back
and hug every parent i ever sat with
because i didn't get it and now i do
and the book is a
masterpiece on walking through things
like
when those images pop back in your head
and you think they're going to take take
you know take over right yeah yeah and
here's how you do that here's how you
move on here's how you can let those
things go and here's how you don't
become captive by those by those
thoughts that pop in your head or those
pictures that pop in your head or
i can't get this one particular scene
out of my mind or your heart just starts
raising those kind of things
um it's a masterpiece walking through um
each one of those situations and i think
you and your husband should read it
together and um when you're ready and it
could be a really shape-shifter for your
family
awesome we will definitely do that then
cool
so i want to tell you
it's a blessing to talk to you you're a
gift and
so many people out there deal with grief
in such deep and profound ways and um
i'm grateful that you shared your story
with us
thank you thank you i appreciate your
advice i really do well we'll be
thinking about you please when you're um
new baby what's girl or boy coming
surprise surprise
do you have a name yet because john is
amazing
i'll let my husband know he's really big
in the name so
i just think john's a great name that's
all i'm saying james terrible name do
not name james but john might be a great
name that's all i'm saying
and um when
the surprise is born if you will send us
a photo let us know and we will be
cheering you on
okay i will do that awesome hey thank
you so so much for the call thank you
for your vulnerability
um you've got millions of people
thinking about you guys and um grateful
for the call